deep in the amazon jungle various
indigenous leaders have joined forces to
protect their livelihood we accompanied
native trackers during a week as they
police the javari valley reserve an area
twice the size of japan it's the home of
18 tribes 11 of them have had no contact
with the outside world
this part of the river belongs to brazil
where white men do as they please but
ahead of us is the indigenous javadi
territory it's forbidden to all but us
yet we're still in danger in the past
the threat came from oil companies and
loggers the government forced them out
two decades ago when the javadi reserve
was demarcated joel sampaio who used to
make a living cutting down trees in the
area is now helping the indigenous
tribes face a new enemy the increasing
number of poachers and fishermen who
have been sneaking into these remote
lands to steal their food
they've been illegally capturing
endangered and expensive species like
the piranha cool fish and turtles to
export them at high prices to
neighboring colombia and peru
outsiders are depleting this protected
forest of game the local indigenous
tribes hunt and fish just enough to
survive the illegal fishermen catch as
much as they can to sell abroad and make
money they have already had shootouts
with government authorities who tried to
stop them
the patrolmen are few in number but have
been armed by ngos with technology
satellite maps cellular apps and a radio
to communicate with villages inside the
javadi valley
we've been patrolling the takuai river
for two days now and the marubo
indigenous people have been showing us
how poachers and fishermen enter their
lands illegally they find these small
canals as you can see here behind me and
they ride these wooden canoes which are
very small and very hard to find
especially at night
we followed the intruders tracks into
the jungle our guide shows us how they
cleared a path to carry canoes to small
rivers further down which will take them
deep into the forbidden territory it's a
daily 10 kilometer hike through
unchartered lands with an occasional
stop to hunt for food on the way they
find new clues like this empty salt bag
the salt is used to preserve the fish
until they're taken to the market the
fish are taken to tabatinga five hours
down the river in the marketplace
smugglers also sell illegally hunted
alligators and turtles
but the real business is booming just
across the border in the colombian city
of leticia
all the fish here comes from brazil on a
good month this fishery sells 70 tons
the most precious species is the
piraroku one of the largest freshwater
fishes in the world matias pereira tells
us he caught almost 150 last week
i sell them in colombia because the
price here is better than brazil he
claims all the piraduku here are
certified and have come from designated
management ponds in the amazon like this
one but the colombian navy patrolling
the solymoise river says most fish are
illegally caught and smuggled
indigenous leader beto marubo says
illegal fishermen work for international
drug cartels as part of a money
laundering scheme
every little canoe can carry the
equivalent of eight thousand dollars
worth of fish and turtles and there are
many canoes working for one master we
set up our own patrols to prove to the
government what's going on and nobody
sees
he says that unless drastic measures are
taken many more endangered species will
continue to be smuggled out of the
indigenous territory threatening nature
and the livelihood of the tribes manika
yanakiv al-jazeera javadi valley